horror
shame terror fear
[Music]
i don't see things going any differently
if there was a gradual withdrawal the
taliban would have crept in
if we left slowly they would have crept
in slowly we left quickly they crept in
quickly
actually they didn't creep they rolled
over everything
[Music]
[Music]
taliban would have waited and waited
another 20 years if we had stayed there
even longer as dark and
you know
ominous and uncertain as afghanistan's
future is right now with the taliban
taking back over it's important to
remember that
it was just as bad while we were there
thank you
[Music]
this is the chaotic exit that they
feared and that
so many of us tried to warn about and
just no one listened it fell on deaf
ears in the biden administration and
they now own this fiasco they were
warned and warned and warned and they
just did not pay attention they didn't
care
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
coalition forces were there for at least
20 years and
you know training and all the millions
and
actually trillions of dollars that went
into
equipping the afghan military just for
them to
turn around and run for the afghani
president to flee
when they're when their country needed
them the most
[Music]
you